Quincy (00:00.772)
Welcome back to the freeCodeCamp podcast.
I'm Quincy Larson, teacher and founder of
freeCodeCamp.
And each week we talk with developers, entrepreneurs,
and ambitious people who are getting into
tech.
Today, I'm joined by Beau Carnes.
He is a software engineer.
He is a teacher, and he oversees the freeCodeCamp
YouTube channel.
He's joining us from Grand Rapids, Michigan,
USA.
So welcome, Beau.
Beau (00:32.566)
Hey Quincy, thanks for having me on!
Quincy (00:35.024)
Yeah, we're stoked to have you here.
And since this is our first video podcast,
I created a very quick theme song for the
freeCodeCamp podcast, which I am gonna attempt
to play right now.
Quincy (00:51.652)
Free code.
took him podcast with Quince and Lars.
All right.
So let me turn off my amp there.
And, and we're going to dive into the interview.
So of course, Beau you've worked with FreeCodeCamp
for like five years or something like that.
So you and I have so much shared context.
We've talked hundreds of hours probably, but
we're going to attempt to like dive deeper
into your background.
Beau (01:01.707)
Nice.
Beau (01:17.151)
Yup.
Quincy (01:28.516)
Maybe we can start off by talking about your
childhood and like where you grew up.
Beau (01:34.854)
Yeah, sure.
I grew up in Michigan, in Portage, Michigan.
It's just about an hour away from where I'm
living now.
And I, one thing that kind of, there's a few
things that actually relate to what I'm doing
now, which is, my dad got me a QBasic book
when I think I was in maybe middle school
or I can't even remember exactly how old I
was.
And then I would
do it like I think it was called GW Basic
on my computer.
And it was basically just for fun.
I never even really thought about it as a
job at that time.
And then in high school, I was actually in
a video production class and that actually
got me into doing video.
And at the time I had no, obviously I had
no idea what was coming, what I was going
to be doing later in life.
But just looking back on those two experiences
actually impacted me a lot as far as my direction
and where I'm at now.
Quincy (02:32.696)
Yeah, I can imagine.
And I didn't realize that you grew up in Michigan.
There's this like
general kind of rule that like most people
live within four hours of where their mom
lives, at least in America.
That's like people, Americans will move up
to four hours away from their mom.
And that's like the farthest they'll generally
move.
And that's true for me.
I live in Dallas, Texas.
And of course I grew up in Oklahoma city,
which is slightly less than four hours drive
away.
So I think it's interesting that you grew
up just an hour away from where you ultimately
settled and bought your home and started your
family.
Beau (03:07.49)
Yeah.
Quincy (03:07.494)
So that's really cool.
Yeah, and speaking of family, you've got a
pretty big family.
You've got several kids, three kids, right?
Beau (03:15.478)
Yeah, I have three kids.
My oldest is 11, my youngest is six and a
half.
And they're all boys, they're very energetic.
And that's one of my favorite things to do
is just to hang out with my kids.
Quincy (03:30.584)
Yeah.
So family man, Beau cards.
Well, um, I want to dive into, of course,
uh, we can learn a lot more about your interesting
personal life, but I think for people that
have watched the free co-camp YouTube channel,
you've probably seen Beau doing the introductions
for most of the video courses that you publish
and Beau himself, you probably taught.
I don't know, at least a dozen different courses,
maybe two dozen on different WordPress concepts.
MongoDB, lots of Python related courses.
You taught the very popular JavaScript course
that's on freeCodeCamp.
I was surprised to learn that you actually
have a formal educational background in video
production.
Maybe you can tell us a little bit about that
and what inspired you to go down that route.
Beau (04:18.814)
Yeah, sure.
I kind of talked a little bit about it when
I took the video production class in high
school.
And that's actually my first degree.
I got a bachelor's degree in video production
at a traditional four year school in Michigan.
And I actually worked in video production
for a little while.
And then I kind of decided I wanted a job
where I was interacting with people more,
making more of an impact.
And I decided to go back to school for teaching.
and I was an elementary school teacher and
I taught all the way up through high school.
And I really enjoyed that for a little while.
And I guess most teachers, I guess the average
length is about five years that they're a
teacher.
And after about five years, I started thinking
about some other things.
I think I got a little bit burnt out on that.
And I really like working with youth, but
I wanted to do it kind of on the side and
not as my full-time job.
And that's when I kind of decided to pursue
software development where I never thought
about it previously, but I had a little bit
of experience when I was younger, like I was
saying, and I got a degree in software development.
And now I'd never really thought about this
at the time, but now I realize I'm kind of
combining all of those things, video production,
teaching and software all when it comes to
like teaching courses on YouTube.
Quincy (05:42.873)
Yeah, it's
It's hard to imagine like a better type of,
you know, job for you than running the free
code camp community, YouTube channel, because
you do get to not only be a teacher, but you
get to also work with other teachers.
And at the same time, you get to apply all
your software engineering know-how from working
as an engineer and also from, uh, of course,
like going to this computer science program,
your computer science program was, uh, I guess
non-traditional in the sense that it's an
undergraduate degree program, but you were
able to complete it.
quickly and very inexpensively and you did
that through Western Governors University
and I'm in the show notes the description
below I've linked to an article where you
talk about essentially how you like completed
the entire degree in about six months maybe
you can give us some background and how you
were able to do that
Beau (06:20.035)
Mm-hmm.
Beau (06:34.77)
Yeah, so one cool thing about Western Governors
University is that you kind of can go at your
own pace.
So every class either has a final exam, where
to usually take it like an exam center, or
a final project that's graded by some graders.
And if you pass the exam or pass the final
project, you can pass the course.
And you can basically work at your own pace.
So if you want, you can go do it very, very
quickly.
And I already talked about how it's kind of
burnt out on teaching, I was just very motivated
to move on to something new.
And that kind of gave me the motivation to
basically go as quickly as possible through
this degree.
So I just really scheduled out my day where
I had a very strict schedule of when I was
gonna work on my coursework and I was able
to stick to that schedule really well.
And I had every, I had very distinct goals.
Like I'm gonna...
pass this class by this date, this class by
this date, and I would kind of rearrange,
like if I felt like, oh, I'm not gonna meet
my goal, then I would either maybe stay up
later, maybe not do something with friends,
or there were actually a few times where I
took a day off of work as a teacher just so
I could meet my goal to pass the class by
a certain deadline.
So I just like got through it super quick,
and you pay for every six months.
So I only had to pay for one,
one six month period, because I was able to
get through it so quickly.
It did help.
I did have some classes transfer in, and I
did have, I guess, a little bit of prior knowledge
in programming.
So that kind of helped a little bit too.
Quincy (08:16.184)
Yeah, and my understanding is one of the reasons
you were doing this was because as a teacher,
you had student loan debt forgiveness after
a certain amount of service as a teacher in
the public school system.
Beau (08:51.833)
Uh, yeah,
I should actually get some more student loans
so I can get them forgiven.
And the truth is that I don't know for sure
if I would have ever done the degree in software
development if I didn't have that motivating
me.
At first I was actually thinking about doing
a master's in mathematics.
I thought that would actually kind of go along
with what I was already doing.
Maybe would open up to a teacher to community
college, but I ended up switching to software
development and I'm really glad I did
my current role.
Quincy (09:26.328)
Yeah.
Wow.
So essentially you kind of got a free accredited
computer science degree in six months because
it was money that you didn't ultimately have
to spend out of pocket because it was, it
was already on the, on the, I guess, chopping
block for getting, uh, reimbursed essentially
by the government.
Yeah, that's pretty cool.
It's very resourceful.
And I think that like hints to the general
resourcefulness.
Beau (09:45.598)
Yeah, that's true.
Quincy (09:53.008)
of Beau Carnes in general.
Like you're an extremely like scrappy, make
do with little type guy.
And that's always kind of like impress me
about you.
I
I've really enjoyed like reading about you
and like the newspaper, for example, like
I think what city were you living in where
you were able to like, uh, move into like
a, an old home and like fix it up.
And, uh, I know that I read about it in like
a local newspaper cause I was like Googling
you at one point.
Beau (10:10.702)
I'm sorry.
Beau (10:22.307)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah, we used to live in Saginaw and in
both Saginaw and Grand Rapids, we did kind
of choose to live in kind of a more lower
income neighborhood.
And I've both places I've kind of gotten involved
with a local community center.
Like in Grand Rapids, I'm on the board of
directors of this local community center that's
doing a lot of work with the youth in the
neighborhood.
I try to volunteer there.
So I just
I guess I just have a desire to use my time
to kind of give back to others, especially
youth.
And yeah, there was an article when we were
in Saginaw, back when there was a printed
newspaper, we had an article in the printed
newspaper about what we were doing in Saginaw.
Quincy (11:10.468)
Yeah, well, your desire to continue to teach,
of course, comes through in the YouTube channel.
But my understanding is you also run a my
daughter's like scowling at me.
She's scowling.
Take my phone here.
You want my phone?
All right.
Here.
I'll just leave it here.
She loves to take it and then watch Zelda
tears of the kingdom related videos.
Um, so.
Beau (11:35.998)
I've been playing with that with my kids right
now.
We always have like a family game that we
do with the kids or something that we do like
a few times a week and we're doing Tears of
the Kingdom right now.
Quincy (11:46.364)
Awesome.
Yeah, I've heard it's an amazing game, like
a sandbox type game where you can just
Beau (11:49.842)
Yeah, we just take turns playing.
We all watch and then we kind of take turns.
Like the kids will play, then I'll play.
So, yeah.
Quincy (11:53.24)
Yeah, that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
And we did that with breath of the wild, but
I just got some burnt ones, although let me
do like anything else.
So I haven't played tears of the kingdom at
all.
And it gives me like, kind of like a nice
like they'll come in and say, daddy, can you
help me beat this boss?
Like, I've never even played that game.
It's like the get out of jail free card so
I can keep working while they while they play
on their switch.
But um,
Beau (12:01.868)
Yeah.
Quincy (12:18.316)
One of the things that is really cool because
you seem to have this desire to help out in
the community and also to teach kids is that
you're also still actively involved in robotics,
um, in robotics club and, and teaching youth,
uh, about like programming and robotics through,
through this.
Can you talk about that a little bit?
Beau (12:39.174)
Yeah, yeah.
So for quite a while, like back when I was
in SAG and I started this before I even had
kids of my own actually, uh, coaching a FIRST
Robotics team.
So FIRST Robotics, um, is a, an organization
that's basically all over the world and they
do local robotics competitions and there's
different levels.
There's like elementary school level, middle
school level, high school level.
And so I've been coaching teams for quite
a while now, including this year, I coached
a team.
And so now I get to actually coach the teams
that my kids are on.
So when I first started, I was coaching just
only other people, other kids from other families,
which I still enjoyed.
And now it's kind of my kids are old enough
to be able to be on teams.
And so it's something I really enjoy doing
where there's kind of different levels.
This year, it was the first Lego league where
we build a Lego robot.
And then there's a...
eight foot by four foot table with all these
stations on it.
And there's, we have to program a robot to
accomplish objectives at different stations.
And then at the competition, all the schools
have been basically preparing their robots
to do the exact same, uh, the exact same object,
objectives.
And then we see at the competition who can
score the most points by doing all the objectives
on the table.
And it's all autonomous.
You have to pre-program the robot.
So you can't really control it with a controller.
And so it kind of uses, it helps the kids
learn programming.
So I'm able to kind of use some of my programming
skills and teaching skills to be able to teach
the kids how to do some basic programming
with the robots.
Quincy (14:17.552)
Yeah.
Well, what are you focused on now?
What are your major projects now?
Beau (14:25.782)
Oh, yeah, I mean, I guess you mean with Freeco
Camp, outside of Freeco Camp, or both?
Quincy (14:38.004)
Sorry.
I was trying really hard not to have a coughing
fit because now I have to like edit this.
Um, yeah, the best editing is when you don't
need to do any editing.
Beau (14:44.77)
Ha ha.
Beau (14:50.743)
Uh huh.
Quincy (14:54.16)
So let me take two minutes.
I'll be right back.
Beau (15:00.08)
Okay.
Quincy (16:31.368)
Hi, Beau.
Sorry I'm back.
And hopefully the coughing doesn't...
I mean, I've been coughing like crazy for
two weeks, basically.
Really for like a month.
But...
Quincy (16:44.476)
Hopefully it doesn't completely derail the
conversation.
I was actually struggling when you were asking
a question, trying to figure out how to mute.
Beau (16:56.334)
I just realized that I was on mute.
I forgot that I had muted.
Quincy (17:01.647)
Do you know whether there's a hockey I mean
you just cuz
Beau (17:04.636)
Um, I don't know.
I just clicked that mute button.
I don't know if there's a key that does it
Quincy (17:10.276)
There should be a...
Beau (17:15.223)
Cough.
Quincy (17:15.824)
hockey sorry uh... we're gonna get all of
this out
Beau (17:19.113)
Mm-hmm.
Quincy (17:27.816)
I mean the plus one, they don't have a keyboard
shortcut.
Beau (17:31.606)
Yeah, it seems like there should be one.
Quincy (17:33.496)
Yeah, because it's like weird to like have
to like look around and like on something
but yeah, okay
I guess they think their software is so good
that like it shouldn't need a mute because
it'll just be smart enough to not.
Okay.
So let me ask you that most recent question.
I was just trying to say a quick short question
because I could feel the cough coming on and
I didn't want to.
I wanted to give you a second to talk while
I was coughing.
So if I'm clearly coughing, just keep talking
and Okay.
Beau (18:02.944)
Okay.
Quincy (18:09.636)
So we were talking about your robotics club.
And I know you have a passion for robots in
general.
And in fact, you, in addition to being father
of three and running the Freeco Camp Community
YouTube channel, you have another channel,
which is quite popular, called Robot Family.
Maybe you could talk a little bit about the
origin of that channel and what your goals
are with it.
Beau (18:34.706)
Yeah, so I have this channel called Robot
Family.
It's the target audience is families and basically
a younger audience.
And I primarily feature fun scripted stories
with robot toys as characters.
And I started it probably about five years
ago.
I just had a robot named Cosmo.
It's just like a cool robot toy.
And I had the idea.
I wanted to, I want, basically I wanted something
fun to do with my kids.
And I also wanted to see if there's some,
if I could eventually get companies to send
our family free robots for our kids to use.
And it's worked out exactly like that, exactly
as planned.
So I started this channel and we started by
doing it.
First we were just like, I was buying robots
and we were doing kind of unboxings and showing
them and pretty quickly.
I was able to get companies to send us some
robots for the channel.
And then eventually we kind of transitioned
to not, we started, eventually we don't do
unboxings anymore.
We just do these fun scripted stories with
the robots as characters.
And it's the channels continue to grow.
It has over 250,000 subscribers now.
And I'm, and even this year I'm kind of trying
to bring it to the next level basically.
where like I was started, I was, I've been
kind of, uh, relative, sometimes inconsistent
with the posting schedule, but I already have
a goal this year to schedule, to post one
a year.
And I'm just trying, or no, what, one, one
video a month, one main video a month.
And then maybe some other like minor, like
less, less time intensive videos where in
the past, sometimes it wasn't even that many
videos.
And so now I actually, I'm developing a better
system.
where I'm now hiring people to write the videos
and hiring people to edit the videos.
So I just have to suit the videos and that
allows me to kind of put out more content.
It would be one thing if I was doing it full
time but since it's just like a side project
I don't have like all the time to kind of
invest in it.
So I try to figure out how can I make my time
like stretch more where what can I do that
what things can I hire out so I can basically
produce more content.
Beau (20:57.639)
So it's been going pretty well.
Quincy (20:59.384)
Yeah, and it's interesting that you're finding
people to help you with that.
Have you, uh, being somebody who's interested
in robotics and automation, have you, uh,
made use of automation very much for running
or, um, you know, any aspect of the production
of that channel?
Beau (21:19.222)
Um, no, I think I haven't done a lot of automating
things besides just like, like I said, trying
to kind of get a good system for how I can,
um, have someone write it, have someone edit.
And then once, once I
It was hard to implement a system of having
people help at first because the way I was
shooting the videos It was very hard to have
someone edit it based on how I was shooting
the videos because I had to remember all these
things In my head, but then I realized I'm
gonna actually have to really change the system
so it can be more efficient So that's not
really automating but it's kind of related
where really thinking about the system in
place That's gonna make the process go smoother
and easier
Quincy (22:06.776)
Awesome.
Yeah, well, I like to think of it as like
you can delegate and you can automate and
like either of those two things can help you
ultimately concentrate on whatever it is that
you're kind of where you're adding the most
value to whatever the output is.
Beau (22:26.13)
I guess the thing that's closest to automating
was, I do use ChatGP to help with the channel.
Like ChatGP will help me think of script ideas.
I've even written a few videos with ChatGPT.
I did one where we had a, we have a yearly
tradition of a Christmas video where our kids
are in, our kids aren't in all the videos,
but they are in some videos.
And we have a weekly, yearly Christmas tradition
where the-
all the presents get stolen and it's a mystery
to see how to find the presents.
So we just had our fourth annual and this
year I was kind of inspired by like the night
before Christmas and these other poems and
I was like, what if, what if the entire video
was rhyming couplets?
So I actually, um, I got the, I got a script,
I actually hired someone to write a script
and then I put it into chat GPT and said,
convert this to rhymes.
So then
it converted the script to all rhyming couplets.
And then I had to do some tweaking to make
some parts sound better, but I realized that's
actually a good use out of ChatGPT to convert
something into rhymes.
And then the whole video is a rhyming video.
Quincy (23:34.512)
Yeah.
Very cool.
Yeah, that's a, that's the first time I've
heard of someone basically taking a script
teaching as a discipline is that you yourself
have to have really good mastery of the subject
before you can really teach it.
And in some ways, teaching further solidifies
your own understanding of it.
What have you really enjoyed the most about
teaching and about preparing like instructional
design, essentially video courses, putting
them out there.
Beau (24:26.23)
Yeah, you're right that teaching can help
you learn things.
And that's actually how I learned JavaScript
kind of, I mean, I had already kind of gone,
when I was first learning the code, I had
already went through a lot of the free code
camp curriculum.
That's actually the main way I learned JavaScript.
But then I decided to start my own personal
YouTube channel before I was involved with
free code camp, where I would teach little
bits of JavaScript.
It's called JS nuggets.
And every video is like a different JavaScript
concept.
And that's really how I really started to
learn JavaScript.
It was like, I knew, I already kind of knew,
knew about it, but to actually teach it, I
had to research and make sure, make sure I
really understood it to be able to actually
teach it to other people.
And that's kind of continued as I work with
the FreeCodeCamp channel and create courses,
um, I definitely obviously have to know the
content before I'm able to teach it.
And so it's kind of a great.
motivator to learn new technologies and to
learn new things.
When I know I'm going to teach a course on
this topic, so I have to kind of deep dive
into the content, the topic.
I have to kind of try out myself and really
kind of come to a good understanding before
I could teach it to others.
So that's one of the things I like about creating
courses is just learning new things and solidifying
my knowledge.
Quincy (25:49.882)
Yeah.
Beau (25:50.01)
and then just being able to help others by
being able to kind of share what I've learned
about that technology.
Quincy (25:56.424)
So in a way, the fact that the course has
to come out is kind of like an extrinsic motivator
for you to really understand things and make
sure you're getting things right.
Because when you publish a video course, it's
not like publishing an article where somebody
points it out and you can just go easily update
it.
It's pretty hard to update YouTube videos.
YouTube is pretty unforgiving in terms of
being able to do like in situ edits, right?
Have you experienced a situation where you
got something wrong on YouTube and like, what
did you do?
Beau (26:33.27)
Well, that's definitely a motivator to, when
you learn something on your own, and you're
using it, and if you make a little mistake,
nobody really knows you made that mistake.
But if you're learning something to teach
a course about it, and then you make the course,
if you make mistake, everyone knows that you
made that mistake.
So that kind of motivates you to make sure
you have it right.
But definitely I've still made mistakes.
I've created courses that had errors in it,
and then people, you know, they're always
quick to point them out in the comments.
But I think it's kind of a growing experience,
you know?
I mean, it's, well, first of all, it is kind
of embarrassing to put out there like and
do something wrong.
But my goal is to kind of learn from everybody.
And so I tried, if people are pointing that
out, I try to kind of, I try to internalize
that and actually try to learn from, instead
of getting defensive, I really try to learn.
And then I...
Sometimes if it's on a on a video I can either
put on the description or a comment how to
like what the mistake was or YouTube did kind
of recently come out with a feature called
corrections where you can make it so a card
pops up To say when there's a correction in
the video
Quincy (27:48.824)
Yeah, you can't actually change the video
itself, although you could edit that section
out completely, right?
Beau (27:54.566)
Yeah, so YouTube does have a feature where
you can remove sections of a video, but you
can never add sections of a video.
Quincy (28:01.7)
Yeah.
So, and even if you're doing this, I mean,
let's say you publish something on free code
camp, which, you know, has a lot of people
watching it every day.
And you, it's a multi hour course and you
need to make some sort of edit where you remove
something that is factually incorrect or something
like that.
It takes a while for that change to propagate
through YouTube.
And meantime, in the meantime, it could be
hours and hours, thousands of people watching
something that you know is wrong, right?
It.
Beau (28:24.119)
Mm-hmm.
Quincy (28:31.781)
That happens sometimes.
Beau (28:34.482)
Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, if you make it if you remove a section
with the YouTube editor, it can take a few
hours before the new version shows up.
And there are there have been times I don't
know if with any of my videos, but there have
definitely been times where we've posted a
course and a mistake, we'll realize a mistake,
and then we take it down and re republish
it.
And sometimes the mistake isn't from the course
creator.
Sometimes the mistake is on my end where
Putting the course together or some contributors
to the free co-camp channel.
Just give me a video That's already ready
to post but then some contributors Will give
like a lots of little videos I have to edit
together some course that we publish require
a lot more work on my end than others and
Every once in a while there I will do something
wrong and we'll have to take the course down
and republish it But luckily it doesn't happen
too often
But that's always an option that we can remove
a course and republish it, but we don't like
to do that.
Quincy (29:38.564)
Yeah.
Well, one of the things about Free Co-Camps
YouTube channel, this a little bit unique
on YouTube is the sheer size of the courses
we're publishing.
A lot of creators will publish like 20 minute
videos, maybe even one hour video essays,
but it's pretty rare that people are uploading
a, you know, eight hour course or something
like that to YouTube and
Over the years, you figured out lots of compression
tricks to be able to upload larger and larger
videos to the extent that I think you uploaded
a video that was more than four days long,
uh, few, like a month or two ago, right?
Like the, uh, the AWS bootcamp, uh, video
course.
Yeah, that was massive.
And maybe you can talk a little bit about
how you figure out ways to do this.
Cause even YouTube, their engineers are kind
of often asking, Hey, how did you do that?
You know, we've had.
Beau (30:31.742)
Yeah.
Quincy (30:31.786)
Lots of calls with like the VP of XYZ over
at YouTube who's trying to understand like
how we're using it and how we're using it
in such a different way from how most people
are using YouTube as a distribution network.
Beau (30:46.57)
Yeah, our channel definitely does things on
YouTube that other channels aren't doing.
And yeah, like you said, people from YouTube
have kind of talked to, said that we're kind
of an edge case for what we're doing.
And especially when our channel first started,
even less people were coming to these long
courses.
I think now that we've got the free Co-Camp
channel has shown how much people actually
like that.
There's more and more channels posting long
courses.
And-
Yeah, it does get tricky.
I mean, for one, YouTube's official documentation
says that the longest course possible is 12
hours.
And that's just not true.
They just I don't know why it's still out
there.
But their help page, that's what it says.
So sometimes you just have to try things to
see if it works, even if the documentation
says it's not going to work.
And but one thing that is true is the file
size limit.
So I think I think it's
250 gigabytes and so That so that's one of
the biggest things that we have to work around
because like this four-day course as you can
imagine it's hard to fit that into a 250 gigabyte
file so that really the biggest secret is
the dot web in format I don't know this for
sure, but I think that YouTube that's like
the.webm format I think is the main format
YouTube uses internally.
And it seems like the.webm format can compress
things a lot more, and still have pretty good
quality.
So especially when I'm creating any course
that's like over 24 hours long, it, it takes
me a long time to finally get that course
up.
Because I'll have to sometimes I'll have to
export multiple, sometimes I'll have to export
multiple files.
from my video editing software, because it
cannot, my video editing software cannot export
over 24 hours at a time.
So, and then I'll have to use another like
FFmpeg or something to combine those exports.
And then I'll have to use, I usually use Handbrake
to convert it to the.webm format.
And then after all that's done, I have, I
mean, it takes up so much space.
I mean, sometimes it can be up to like,
Beau (33:09.918)
sometimes I can get up to like a terabyte,
you know, have all these files, and then,
and then I'll finally get to upload the file
to YouTube.
And sometimes like one, when we first published
the CS 50 course, which was like a pretty,
it was a pretty long course was also.
Yeah, and, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So that was the biggest thing about the CS
50 courses.
Quincy (33:26.636)
It's like 24-25 hours long for the new one,
the newest one.
And it's in 4K.
Beau (33:36.814)
It was 4K, so not only was it a super long
course, it was also 4K.
And this newest one didn't take as long, but
the first one we published that was also similar
length.
We published, I think, maybe two years ago.
It took...
it took actually, I think, four to five weeks
to process on YouTube.
After I uploaded it, it had to finish processing,
and it took over four weeks to process.
And then I had given up on it, I just...
I didn't think it was ever going to finish
processing, but I just left it there just
in case.
And eventually it showed up, showed that it
was done processing and then we could publish
it.
Quincy (34:12.164)
Wow, that's gotta be a record.
Like I can't imagine that YouTube, I mean,
they're engineers hats off to them.
If they actually have, they don't have something
that kills a process have for four weeks.
Cause that, that is like some crazy processing
time for a single video.
Beau (34:23.203)
Mm-hmm.
Beau (34:28.278)
They must have improved it though because
since then, the processing time isn't never
that long.
It still can be kind of a long time, like
for that four day course.
I think that took maybe like a day to process,
which is still a long time but nowhere near
like the four weeks.
Quincy (34:45.496)
Yeah.
So maybe you can talk a little bit about how
you approach developing courses, because,
as I said, you've developed a lot of courses.
We have a lot of organizations we work with,
you know, Microsoft, Google, and then, of
course, lots of
tech companies like MongoDB, New Relic, and
they'll create grants for Freeco Camp.
And the grant will be like, create a course
around open telemetry, for example, and show
how it works or something like that.
And then.
Essentially, your role is to take a look at
the various tools and figure out, okay, what's
like a full stack project we can build around
this that will be compelling, that'll be interesting.
And we can show people how to use these tools
in addition to a whole bunch of other open
source tools.
So maybe you could talk about what your workflow
is likely.
Let's say for example, um, the spoiler alert,
we're going to be developing a course on this
multiplayer.
uh, server like net code essentially, and
that's going to be pretty exciting.
Uh, but like what will be your process for
developing a game that makes use of net code
and things like that.
And I guess from ideation to actual, you know,
outline development, uh, the more detail you
can go into the better.
Cause I think a lot of people are probably
very interested in how the
video courses get made because they don't
just drop out of the sky in final form.
They are.
There's a long iterative process involved.
Beau (36:17.271)
Mm-hmm.
Beau (36:47.658)
Yeah, yes,
Beau (36:55.974)
If there's any other videos out there, I'll
watch videos that kind of explain it and then
just get as much knowledge of that technology
as possible and then sometimes there'll be
an opportunity to actually ask questions to
the team that creates that technology and
so it kind of really solidify my understanding
and then after that I try to Think of what
an interesting project is gonna be
because we want to teach the topic, but in
an engaging way.
So I want to kind of think what's going to
be an interesting project that people are
going to be maybe interested to create, even
if they don't know about that technology or
they're not maybe, so you want to be able
to have people coming to the video for two
reasons.
One, people that want to learn that technology,
and two, maybe they just are interested in
that project.
So you get more interest in that.
And then after I kind of...
develop the idea, maybe brainstorm different
things, then I will, I guess maybe depending
on the course, I may have to develop some
code, some like the code for the project that
I'm going to teach.
And then sometimes, then I'll generally have
to write a script.
And the script will, they'll usually some
sort of introduction.
And the key part is having a good hook, you
know, you want within the first 30 seconds
or a minute.
you want people to be interested in watching
the rest of the course where sometimes I'll
actually do that I'll have an idea for what
I'm gonna do for the hook and the introduction
but I'll do that at the end after I've maybe
demonstrated how to create a project then
I'll then I'll write the introduction and
put a lot of time into how I'm gonna hook
people so they're actually interested in watching
the whole thing and the way I do courses everyone
kind of makes them different but
generally, the most of the course, I won't
be on camera, I'll be demonstrating something
through screen sharing, and I'll be just recording
my voice.
And then I'll generally have just certain
sections where I'm on camera.
So I'll use like the introduction, the conclusion,
and then maybe a few transition points.
So I'll write all that and like what I'm going
to do for that, then I record it all.
And then I just basically kind of combine
it all together.
Beau (39:19.062)
Um, uh, edit out all my mistakes.
Like anytime, anytime I'm sharing my screen
and, uh, on a course, you can know that there's
way more edits than it looks like because,
uh, I make so many mistakes and I'm creating
it, but then I have to edit it.
So it makes it looks like I'm new.
What I was talking about on the first take.
So, uh, it kind of can take a while to put
it all together.
Um, I mean, also there's a few things I always
think about.
which is one, having good audio.
And I mean, that's a super important thing
for courses, is having good audio.
And then one thing that's kind of surprising
to people is that on the FreeCodeCamp channel,
one third of our viewers are watching on mobile
devices and even more than one third are sometimes
watching on very small screens.
Cause we have viewers all over the world and
we have, and so it's important for any of
our courses, especially ones I'm making is
that the
Any text or code on screen is big enough for
people to be able to read if they're watching
on a small device, because we want to make
this accessible as possible to people all
over the world.
So those are all kind of my, I guess, some
of the broad overview of what I think about
when I'm creating a course.
Quincy (40:33.136)
Yeah.
And you've created an entire guide.
I just call it our YouTube style guide, essentially,
uh, how to create a good technical course.
Um, and, uh, I'm going to include that in
the, um, the show notes, but what are some
of the big mistakes that you've seen people
make?
that you think are like the easiest things
to correct.
The easy wins where people can up their course
creation game if they just remember a few
key concepts.
I mean, you definitely mentioned.
Text size, you definitely mentioned the importance
of quality sound.
People will tolerate like okay-ish video,
but if the audio is bad, then that is a lot
of people will just click off.
YouTube is very, uh, cutthroat, brutal place,
uh, environment for your video to live because
all along the side you've got exciting, you
know, potentially like much more.
uh, sensational than like learning how to
use MongoDB or something like that.
You've got content like that, uh, that can
easily pull you in your attention away and
then also, you know, like.
Reddit and Facebook and all the other websites
are just an alt tab away.
So people can go and do something completely
different.
And, you know, people are, you know, potentially
watching and a, on a bus or like, there's
so many different.
Beau (41:30.028)
Mm-hmm.
Quincy (41:53.124)
kind of things that can jostle people out
of watching your in-depth course.
Uh, but I guess tips you have for engaging
people and, uh, things that you've, you've
seen people do that you really learned a lot
from and things that you see people do often
that you think are anti-patterns and are probably
undermining their ability to find and retain,
uh, viewership and learners.
Beau (42:20.222)
Yeah, so I would say I think I've maybe here
are the four biggest things.
I mean, the two of them would be the ones
you already said.
So audio quality is really big, is really
important.
And a lot of people don't put enough thought
into that because, you know, I'm seeing so
many people are submitting courses to me for
the free Kokem channel.
So I see all these different levels.
So audio quality and text size are the two
very big things to think about.
And then just the importance of the introduction,
I talked about that a little earlier.
But some people just go right into kind of
teaching without giving anybody a reason for
why they should watch.
So it's very important within the first 30
seconds to a minute to explain very clearly
what the course is about, what the people
are going to learn, why the why people should
watch should want to learn that, that content.
and why people should learn that content from
you.
Because there's so many courses around so
many different topics.
So you went very quickly to explain why someone
should watch that and why someone should watch
it from you.
And then at least on the FreeCocam channel,
we have viewers from, like I said, all over
the world.
A lot of viewers don't speak English as their
first language.
And so it makes it even more important to
basically have...
speech that is very easy to understand.
It could be like enunciation, pronunciation,
audio quality.
So like if you're a native English speaker,
I think it's kind of easier to understand,
maybe low lower quality audio.
But if you if you are kind of an speaking
English as a second language, you're just
learning English, it becomes even more important
for that to be very easy to understand.
So that can really make a big difference as
well.
So I think those are those are the kind of
the four high level things that I would think
about.
But there's like I said, you mentioned the
articles, there's plenty of other tips in
the article if people want to learn more.
Quincy (44:25.528)
Yeah, okay, just to recap, high quality sound,
large text, an introduction that establishes
like, why?
You know, the who, what, where, why, but essentially
why people should stick around and invest
the time in doing this course.
And then forth, just consideration for non
native English speakers.
And on that note, you have been very active
in mentoring.
uh, Estefania who has launched the Spanish
YouTube channel, which is also quite popular.
It's one of the more popular Spanish language
YouTube channels now.
And, uh, you've also been working very hard
on trying to figure out ways to improve the
quality of subtitles.
We've asked for lots of features from YouTube,
for example, when we talk to YouTube, uh,
deal.
What do you think the near future for localization
is?
Maybe you can talk a little bit about like
what Mr. Beast has been doing, for example,
and some of the other ways that people have
been trying to make their content more accessible
to the non-English speaking world.
Beau (45:37.802)
Yeah, one of the relatively new features that
YouTube rolled out was different language
tracks.
So we can put, we can upload, for instance,
a Hindi language track or a Spanish language
track.
So it's our main video, but instead of so
before you could already upload different
subtitle tracks and you could change what
language the subtitles are for.
But now you can upload different language
tracks in your videos.
And so we have been experimenting with that.
And at our scale, it's kind of prohibitive
to actually have someone personally read,
like dub the courses.
So we've been looking into various ways to
use AI tools and other things to create these
dubbed voices.
And I think eventually YouTube is just gonna
offer that automatically.
Like right now,
You have to upload a different dub track,
but my guess is in the near future YouTube
will have live dubbing in other languages
right on the channel.
Quincy (46:46.948)
Yeah.
And that will be amazing because, uh, whenever
we, you know, the Spanish channel, everything
is done by Spanish speaking creators.
And that is like the very top level of experiences
when you actually have a teacher who speaks
your language, who understands, you know,
not, not that like Spanish is a monoculture.
It's a whole bunch of different countries,
but, um,
you know, can make like cultural references
and explain things in a way that like an,
an AI generated like translation of a script
won't necessarily capture that nuance.
So, um, yeah, like we're, we're going to continue
to create, uh, video courses in other world
languages, even after such technology exists.
But it's, it's very exciting just because
FreeCodeCamp has more than a thousand full
length courses on
I mean, most programming topics, like we have
a course on cobalt, right?
We have, and we have courses on all the newest
stuff, like pretty, pretty much any new technology
mojo course, for example.
So you can imagine like, Wikipedia, about
half the traffic to Wikipedia goes to the
English edition.
Beau (47:43.98)
Yeah.
Quincy (48:00.08)
half the traffic goes to the other world languages.
So it's like essentially doubling the amount
of impact our charity can have in terms of
our mission, which is helping people learn
to code for free.
So yeah, here's hoping that YouTube rose those
features out and in the meantime, we'll continue
experimenting with them.
If we can economically do something to add
dubbing or certainly if we can add new captions,
you know, in different languages, we're gonna
do that.
Right now you...
You can watch Freeco Camp in any world language
you want, uh, with, with the, uh, auto translation,
but YouTube's interface makes it like four
or five clicks to be able to access that.
And they, I was just helping somebody understand
that the other day and it's still, you know,
four or five clicks.
I think it's, you have to click subtitles,
then you have to click English and then you
click the gear again, the setting again, and
then you go, you know, trans auto translate,
and then you choose your language.
So it's like four or five clicks, uh, to be
able to get
Beau (48:51.21)
Mm-hmm.
Quincy (48:58.012)
captions, but you can do that.
And I do that all the time because I watch
a lot of videos that are not in English, um,
like documentaries and things like that.
And, uh, I'll, I'll go in and get the auto
translated.
English is kind of like a first-class language
in the sense that I think it's fewer clicks
for an English speaker, just because it is
kind of like a major world language.
But, um, yeah, that's been an incredibly powerful
feature and translation just gets better and
better all the time.
You know, I, I studied a lot of languages
and I'm just
Beau (49:14.274)
Mm-hmm.
Quincy (49:27.356)
blown away.
I talked to, I'll take this and I'll show
it to like my wife who's a Chinese, a native
Chinese speaker.
I'll talk to my native Spanish speaking friends
and I'll be like, does this look like natural?
And they'll be like, oh yeah, that's very
natural.
Where did you get that?
It'll be like, GPT came up with it, you know?
So, uh, yeah, it's, um, it's really impressive,
uh, how powerful these tools are getting in
freeco camp.
I'll say it like on both of our behalf, we
are applying the latest and greatest tools
as quickly as we can work.
Beau (49:41.178)
Uh huh.
Quincy (49:54.748)
where they're ready for prime time.
You know, there are lots of experimental tools
that are frankly not ready for prime time
and you won't see us generally use those.
But mature tools that do work, we are gonna
adopt them.
So what are your, I guess your biggest, what
are you most excited about with the main English
Freeco Camp YouTube channel?
Beau (49:59.862)
Mm-hmm.
Beau (50:18.306)
Well, yeah, I'm well first of all, I'm excited
that we're getting a little closer to 10 million
subscribers So that will be like a huge milestone
that I think maybe in the next year or so
we'll get to Because you know when I start
I when I started working with free coke camp,
we had 75,000 subscribers So that a lot some
people think I just started the channel because
they see me so much But I didn't start the
channel that was Quincy, but I joined when
there was 75,000 subscribers
and now we're getting close to 10 million.
So that's been pretty exciting.
But I guess as far as other excitement, I'm
just excited to basically continue what we've
been doing to post more courses.
And like what a lot of my time is around what
you were just talking about, which is getting,
making it more, making our courses more accessible
to more people in the world through better
subtitles, better dubbing and...
just continuing to experiment with, I guess,
different formats.
And I just hope that we can continue to be
kind of the premier place where people are
watching software tutorials.
And we also want to kind of continue to publish
more and more very massive comprehensive courses,
to the point where, where
People don't need to even go to Udemy or some
of these other places because they know they
can just go to the FreeCocamp YouTube channel
and they'll be able to find a high quality
course and whatever they're trying to learn.
Quincy (51:52.664)
Absolutely.
Yeah.
One of the things that I'm really excited
about the YouTube channel is that we are publishing
full length university courses created by
free code camp.
Yeah.
So of course, Beau, you were able to go to
Western Governors University.
Excellent.
Accredited university online.
Very economical.
There's some other what I call ultra low cost
universities out there here in the United
States.
But our goal is to eventually have a free
Beau (52:01.068)
Oh yeah.
Quincy (52:20.144)
computer science degree program like bachelor
in computer science and associate in mathematics
and
We're going to be publishing the lectures
from those on YouTube.
In fact, we already have the lectures from
one of the first mathematics courses up there,
and we're going to get the lectures from the
second one up, hopefully, within the next
month or two.
And then we have a total of 40 full length
university courses that we're going to publish
on FreecoCamp's YouTube channel.
So that's something I'm really pumped about
that.
I'll just add on top of what you were saying.
Beau (52:52.266)
Yeah, and I'm excited about that too.
There's so many things to be excited about,
so.
Quincy (52:56.976)
Well, I want to talk a little bit more about
you personally, because you're an interesting
dude, objectively.
I guess, subjectively, because I can't speak
objectively.
From where I'm standing, you're very interesting.
One of the things that strikes me is the parallels
between you and Richard Feynman, of course,
the famous, I think it was like Caltech.
Beau (53:07.891)
Hehehehe.
Quincy (53:19.804)
mathematics and physics professor, one of
the greatest teachers to ever live that we
know about, you know, there could be incredible
teachers in, you know, human prehistory and
antiquity that are lost to time, but he was
definitely like one of the greatest teachers
of the 20th century.
And he was a very, I don't mean to say this
in like a pejorative way, but he was kind
of an eccentric dude.
Like he loved going really deep and learning
like magic tricks and, you know,
You are somebody who literally owns like stiltwalking.com
or something.
Was it, what's the website that you have?
stiltwalker.net where you can hire VoCarns.
You can hire VoCarns to be a stiltwalker at
your carnival or your, your state fair, right?
Beau (53:56.234)
Yes, yes, still Walker net.
I haven't done anything with it for a while
though.
Beau (54:08.882)
Yeah, yeah, so I used to do it a lot more.
I haven't been doing it as much lately if
I still sometimes do it where I walk on stilts.
I juggle clubs So I'll be on the stilts juggling
clubs and I'll go to different events and
I've done a lot of parades I've done a lot
of different like fairs and festivities So
I don't do it quite as much as I used to but
i'm still getting out there sometimes and
I i'm trying to pass off some of it to my
kids.
Um
because another thing I used to do a lot was
magic shows.
And so my oldest son has been, this year will
be his fourth year in a row doing a magic
show at his school talent show.
So I've been kind of passing off some of my
knowledge to him and helping him prepare to
perform, to do these magic performances.
So yeah, there was a while where I was actually...
booking a lot like tons of paid gigs and now
I mainly just do it kind of for fun at different
events but I there was a period of my life
where I was booking paid gigs like for still
walking and magic shows like all over the
state of Michigan so
Quincy (55:21.544)
That is really cool.
Yeah.
Definitely.
If we ever have like a really like free co-camps,
a small charity, we don't have a lot of resources.
We don't have like big in-person conferences
or anything.
It's not like dream force that takes over
half of San Francisco that Salesforce has
every year.
We would never have the budget for something
like that.
But if we do ever have like an event, like
a, you know, an Apple keynote type thing,
we absolutely have got to get you on stilts
at that event.
That would be so cool.
Yeah.
Well, though I just, I
Beau (55:45.358)
Okay, I'm in, I'm in.
Quincy (55:51.178)
for the freeCodeCamp community.
I'm proud, of course, to have you on the freeCodeCamp
team working alongside me and Estefania and
all these other teachers slash software engineers,
many of whom have classroom teaching experience,
like you have five plus years of special ed
teaching and robotics club and things like
that.
And yeah, we're just like.
thrilled to have you here.
It's a huge point of pride that we can say
like, yeah, we have people like Beau Carnes
working at freeCodeCamp.
So yeah, I just want to publicly acknowledge
that like, I'm, you know, over the moon and
everything you're doing.
And I want to thank you again.
Beau (56:31.554)
Well, I really appreciate it.
Yeah, I respect you so much.
So just hearing all that coming from you is
really meaningful.
Thank you.
Quincy (56:38.168)
Yeah.
And I just want to encourage everybody to
check out some of Beau's writing, which I've
included in the show notes.
Again, uh, his story of how he got his second
degree, his computer science, uh, software
development degree from Western governors
university while he was raising two kids while
he was working as a teacher and, uh, check
out Beau's personal website, which has some,
some cool quirky stuff on it.
And of course,
If you are a creator and you want to create
courses, or if you're just a teacher, you're
teaching a community college, a university,
wherever, uh, high school level, and you just
want to help share your passion and your wisdom
that you've developed around math, programming,
technology.
reach out to Beau and read his style guide.
It will teach you everything he's learned
over the course of many years, being on YouTube
and creating tutorials.
And yeah, I hope everybody has a fantastic
day.
Signing off, everybody.
Till next week, happy coding.
Beau (57:42.25)
Bye everybody.